right
it's very good
wow
are you
it is unfortunately
the system itself
very
okay
at least it's happening
okay
uh
is
okay
hmm
yes
yes
so
this
um
feature is feeling good that
it's a nature's healing ad exactly
you
okay
uh
uh
[Music]
check
thank you
yeah yeah
uh
so
uh
hi everyone
happy monday
[Applause]
okay just a couple of items at the top
and i know there's a heart out here for
a gather time so we'll work to
get through as many people as possible
and if our friends in the front row
could
help with that so we can get to the back
row we'll come circle back around if
that works okay
a couple things at the top uh as you all
know uh the president is launching his
help is here tour to communicate
directly
with americans about how the rescue plan
is helping them and their families
the tour will make clear that help is
here and that we're on the path towards
crushing the virus and rebuilding
our economy a number of these pieces you
know but just to add a few more details
so tomorrow the president will travel to
delaware county pennsylvania
to highlight how the rescue plan invests
in small businesses a key component of
the package
including minority owned businesses so
they can rehire and retain
workers while keeping them safe the vice
president and second second gentleman
will be in denver
also meeting with small business owners
that will be a big piece we're
highlighting tomorrow
on wednesday the first lady will travel
to concord new hampshire to underscore
how the american rescue plan
provides 130 billion dollars to help
schools
reopen the second gentleman will convene
a listening session in albuquerque new
mexico
with working women including teachers
and education
secretary cardona will do a remote local
media tour to talk about school
reopenings and i think you
can see what the theme is of that day on
thursday the administration will
showcase
how the american rescue plan provides
emergency aid to cover
background help homeowners catch up on
their payments and provide funding for
families recovering
from homelessness and then on friday uh
president biden and vice president
harris will travis
travel to georgia as you all already
know to underscore how they and
congressional democrats fulfilled their
promise
in delivering 400 1400 checks to finish
the job
of two thousand dollars in direct relief
to millions of americans
uh the second piece of just the last
piece i should say at the top is
many of you saw the news out this
morning uh that gene
sperling will be joining the uh team
here
to run point on the implementation of
the rescue plan
i've known him for a long time i worked
with him previously but
to give you a few highlights gene has
spent more than a decade at the highest
level
of government including a senior
treasury official and as the only person
to serve as nec
director twice as we've talked about in
a bit in here there are a number of
economic
uh officials who will be playing rules
and implementation so he has
especially interesting and relevant
background in helping pull all those
levers
gene was also uh played a key role in
helping steer detroit out of bankruptcy
and on the path to renewal any
quarterback support for small businesses
and economic assistance for unemployed
americans he will work with the heads of
white house policy councils
and key leaders at federal agencies so
we can get funds out the door quickly
maximize its impact accelerate the work
that the administration is doing to
crush covid
and rescue our economy and as i've noted
in here before
the president felt it was important to
have a point pertinent who could
of course pull all of these lovers with
that go ahead zeke
thanks jen millions of americans started
to receive
direct health checks over the weekend
has the president
giving any thought to how he wants
americans to use that money
does he particularly want them to spend
it to stimulate the economy
well that's a great question i think
that uh the president believes that
this relief will help americans get
through this difficult period of time
and they will use it for different means
some americans will use it to ensure
they can put food on the table
that certainly is a form of stimulus
some will use it to
ensure they can pay their rent that's
also a form of stimulus
some will use it to um you know pay back
some
loans they may have taken out it's it's
really up to family to family he wants
them to have the discretion on how
they're
utilizing these funds but he pushed for
this additional
1400 dollar check and was adamant about
that because he knows people need a
bridge to get
to the other side of this economic
downturn on a different subject the
vatican
today said it would not bless same-sex
unions at the presence of
catholic does he have a personal
response to that
i don't think he has a personal response
uh to the vatican no
uh he continues to believe uh and
support same-sex unions as you know and
he's long had that position
i uh finally uh does the president
the president's ahead of the democratic
party what message is he sending by not
calling on the new york governor
um to resign number one number two
tomorrow is the usual weekly call with
governors governor cuomo is still the
head of the national government
association he usually attends is he
still welcome on the white house can be
called
well let me first say that uh like
everyone who as
continues to read stories new
developments seem to happen
uh every day uh we find them troubling
the president finds them troubling
hard to read and every woman who steps
forward
needs to be treated with dignity and
respect
the new york attorney general is
pursuing of course an independent
investigation
against governor cuomo and that is
appropriate and the president believes
that's appropriate as is the vice
president
uh the investigation needs to be both
quick and thorough consistent with how
serious
these allegations are uh and of course
uh our objective though here
uh continues to be to get the coveted
pandemic under control and we don't want
the people of new york or any state to
be impacted negatively we will continue
to work with a range of governors
including governor cuomo who i would
expect would join the call
tomorrow uh we'll leave that up to him
but uh but in order to continue to
coordinate on getting
uh the pandemic under control and
economic assistance out the door
uh go ahead i'll go to your steam next
up go ahead um thanks just two quick
ones and
get how fast the situation has been does
the president believe that
his administration has a handle on
what's happening on the southern border
right now
we certainly do and let me just give you
a bit of an update on a couple of the
steps that
we're taking um you know first let me
say that
like covid obviously different issue but
we recognize this is a
big problem the last administration
left us a dismantled and unworkable
system and like any other problem we are
going to do everything we can
to solve it uh so our focus here is on
solutions let me just walk you through a
couple of the steps and we've done this
a little bit but there's always of
course
developments on considerations that are
underway
so first we've updated or we have not
but cdc has updated guidelines
to return to full capacity this will
help expand capacity to move children
more quickly out of cbp
facilities that's an important step the
implementation of that is of course
ongoing
uh we are uh there is there is now an
embedding at the president's ask
of hhs and or staff with cbp uh which
will allow government to more quickly id
vet
confirm sponsors and family members of
the unaccompanied
minors and will lead to quicker
placement because as you know as all as
you know big issues here are
expediting what's happening at the
border none of these border patrol
facilities are made for children
and we want to move them as quickly as
possible into shelters and then into
homes
fema this was an announcement over the
weekend is now supporting
providing support at the border adding
extra capacity to hhs for quick
processing to avoid overcrowding
this will hope we hope this will help
quickly get children into hhs and orr
facilities and placed
with vetted sponsors and families
president's very focused on expediting
what's happening at the border at every
step in the process
and then this happened on friday but it
didn't receive a lot of there was a lot
going on so i just wanted to
highlight um we rescinded the 2018 mou
between dhs and hhs which we believe
will encourage
families and sponsors to come forward
without fear of additional immigration
enforcement and we've seen this as an
issue
where family members or even sponsor
families are worried that this will mean
they will be tracked and this
over rescinds that um that we're also
looking for additional facilities and
this remains
a focus so uh we recognize this is a
problem we're focused on addressing it
that's just five steps we're taking and
we're continuing
to evaluate what additional steps can be
taken to address the situation at the
border
real quick the 130 billion dollars in
education funding one of the big issues
with past pots of ed funding is it'll be
obligated
but getting it spent takes time will
that be part of gene's mandate
ensuring the money's not just obligated
but it actually goes out the door
to make the fixes that these schools
need to actually get students back into
place
he'll absolutely be coordinating with
the secretary of education secretary
cardona who's going to be holding an
education summit
soon i believe it might be next week i'm
not sure if they've announced it yet so
hopefully i'm not getting ahead of them
and part of that is working with schools
and school districts on
identifying best practices and sharing
them figuring out
how to ensure that the schools who need
funding get the funding there will be a
requirement that
schools who get funding have to do a
report within 30 days of
how they will reopen their schools so a
big part of the implementation of course
will be led by the department of
education
but that is a pivotal part of the rescue
plan and one the americans strongly
support and certainly
gene would have a role in coordinating
that jen is
is mexico doing enough to stem the flow
of migrants across the territory
across the territory from south america
into
into mexico uh you know i think we are
we work extremely closely
with the country of mexico on uh and on
addressing
what is a challenge for us and certainly
a challenge for them
there's always more that can be done uh
steve and i think part of our engagement
is having those diplomatic conversations
and
having discussions about uh what more
can be done at all the borders
and separately on north korea have you
reached out to them that
tried to engage in dialogue and have
they responded in any way
i know there were some reports over the
weekend on exactly that
and so i can confirm that we have
reached out we obviously have a main
series of a number of channels as we
always have had that we can reach out
through we also are focused on
consulting with many former government
officials who've been involved
in north korea policy including from
several prior administrations
and we have and will continue to engage
with other japanese and south korean
allies to solicit input explore fresh
approaches
we've listened carefully to their ideas
including through trilateral
consultations our goal is of course
diplomacy is always our goal
our goal is to reduce the risk of
escalation
but to date we have not received any
response
that they haven't responded well steve
as you know because you follow this
issue closely and i know and have
covered past administration this follows
over a year
without active dialogue with north korea
uh despite
multiple attempts by the u.s to engage
so
diplomacy remains our continues to
remain our first priority
we have i think you can all anticipate
that there will be a continued
expansion of engagement with partners
and allies in the region
and this will of course be a top a topic
of discussion go ahead
yes um can you bottom line for us again
what is the
what is the hope and expectation from
this hope is here toward this week
over the next couple of days a big focus
is we want to take a moment or take some
time more than a moment
to engage directly with the american
people and make sure they understand
the benefits of the package how they can
benefit from the package and how
it's going to help them get through this
difficult period of time in our economy
and our economic recovery
and also give them a sense of how we're
going to use it to help address the
pandemic we recognize that signing the
bill is just a first
step and getting the money out the door
ensuring people know how they can
benefit
how it will help their local communities
is an important part as well you're
trying to shore up
the strong support for the law as it
already exists well
i would say the bill is already quite
positive um
and so but what the president recognizes
from his own experience
uh is that uh when it's a package of
this size
um you know people don't always know how
they benefit
and how what it means for them and uh
last week i was
talking to him about one of the pieces
of the package the checks and he asked
me to explain to him
how do you explain to people how checks
get out the door so this is what's on
his mind
right how do people know how this money
will help their schools
you know how do they know um you know
how this will help
get vaccines in the arms of their
friends and family members and
he believes the american people deserve
every
high-level person from our
administration out there explaining
discussing
taking input and that's what his team
will be doing so well he does that you
know there are a lot of americans
who see him going to take these trips
this week to promote this popular law
and think
okay but why can't he take time to go
down
this week when you've said it before it
takes a lot of resources to get him
there
it's taking a lot of resources to get
him to pennsylvania and georgia this
week
cannot take the time to schedule
something to go there as well well i
would say
that his focus is on developing
solutions
pushing his team encouraging his team to
develop
solutions that will expedite processing
at the border
that will open more facilities that will
ensure kids are
treated with humanity and also treated
safely uh and that's his focus
um and so that's where he's putting his
uh his efforts on immigration
what is the status of allowing cameras
into some of these facilities we've been
asking for weeks about
whether or not the press will ever get a
chance to see either the border patrol
or the hhs facilities we continue
uh to support transparency uh and from
here from the white house and uh dhs
oversees some of the facilities hhs
overseas
facilities i know that they're working
through uh how to
uh provide access in a way that is uh
abides by covid protocols and also
protects the privacy of people who are
being
uh who are staying in those facilities
has the president himself spoke to the
government
no has anyone here the white house is
spoken of not that i'm aware of now
i think go ahead thank you first the
question about workplace safety
osha is up against the deadline set by
president biden to
decide whether or not there needs to be
emergency temporary standards
for uh cobia 19 safety
for the next six months is there any
concern that additional federal
regulations might and the cost of
complying
with them might be a burden on
businesses already trying to
they're already struggling to survive
well first the president's on an
executive order which i know you're
familiar with but
back maybe the third day he was in
office
because he um wants to ensure um that
workers are of course safe
he's asked the american people to do
their part to help quickly beat the
virus
and he's directed osha to determine if
any emergency if an emergency temporary
standard was necessary to protect
workers from covid so his objective is
actually to protect
workers and members of the work force um
the osha has been working diligently but
we of course um
believe we they should have the time to
get it right and time to ensure it's
right
uh and so uh we uh we're waiting for
them to
to make a conclusion and as the voice of
the white house
uh would it how hard would it be to
convince
people in some states that are trying to
open up quickly that
there are new federal rules that they
need to follow instead
well there are no new federal rules yet
um we will let osha put out their
guidelines and then
of course we will work to ensure that
people understand why
and that they support workers being safe
which i think
even many owners of businesses would
support and then on immigration
does fema's arrival at the border mean
that the administration feels what is
happening
down the border is a disaster
one of the steps that the president felt
would help
uh not become a final solution but help
expedite
processing help ensure that uh people
who are coming across the border are
have access
to health and medical care clearly the
numbers are
enormous this is a big challenge and it
certainly is a reflection of
using every level of the federal
government to help address that
specifically their mission is helping
people before
during and after disasters we've heard
you say
that it's a problem that it's a
challenge is it now a disaster
i appreciate the opportunity i do like
your mask um but i will say that
um fema is uh there to help
uh ensure that the people who are at the
border who are coming across the border
uh have access to uh can to hhs and orr
shelters
that we can swiftly place them with
vetted families there are they're
playing a number of roles
uh there uh to address what we feel is a
significant problem and a significant
challenge and i think we haven't
uh we haven't uh stepped i've been
hiding about that
just a quick final one all right dhs
said that the fema plan for 90 days
would be to receive
shelter and transfer unaccompanied
children does that mean that the
federal government now is moving beyond
the message from the last couple weeks
which was
now is not the time to come no we are
cons
we are we are we are doing both um and
uh it's a complicated problem
no doubt about it we are sending the
message clearly in the region
now is not the time to come but also we
want to ensure that people are treated
with humanity
who are children who are unaccompanied
children
that's who we are as a country and so we
are doing both
go ahead thanks jen given what we're
saying
at state legislatures in terms of
tightening voting restrictions
some groups are saying that the white
house should consider reprioritizing
voting rights over infrastructure is
that something that's under
consideration here at the white house
to reprioritize and focus on voting
rights next
uh now that the arp is out well first i
would say that
um hr1 as you all know has passed the
house um
s1 i believe will be uh i think put
forward officially later this week or
that's what reports suggest
we are working closely with uh senators
who we've engaged directly with on this
uh with uh with staff and we are very
deeply engaged in working with members
of the senate and their teams on
how this can move forward i wouldn't say
one is over the other
voting rights and ensuring people have
access to
voting that it is easier or not harder
is a core priority for the president
uh that's why his team is so engaged in
this process
and of course investing in
infrastructure ensuring that we can
create good uh clean energy
union jobs is also a priority uh you
have to walk and chew gum
as president of the united states and
certainly he believes both are
imperative and important
on infrastructure is there concerning
any tax
increases on the uh as related to the
package
would did that that would slow down
economic growth at all
well there isn't a package yet right i
know there's lots of
conversations in in congress and we're
certainly working very closely uh with
them
and consultations and obviously uh the
president will have more to say about
what he wants to pursue next as part of
his build back
better agenda uh the president remains
committed to his pledge from the
campaign
that nobody making under 400 000
a year will have their taxes increased
his priority and focus has always been
on people paying their fair share
and also focusing on corporations that
may not be paying their fair share
either so
that remains his overarching uh approach
uh but there isn't a package yet where
we're talking about paid fors yet so
i expect we can have more conversations
about that down the road
go ahead jen thanks two questions one
the treasury secretary said yesterday
that a wealth tax is something you
haven't decided on yet
and can look at is that on the table as
an approach to pay for some of the next
round of plans from the president
uh well the i know senator warren has
put forward a wealth tax um
and the president shares uh her view
that middle-class families are paying
more
than their fair share and those at the
top are not doing uh their part so
certainly he has that uh shared
objective he laid out during the
campaign
his own plans for fixing this which are
different from senator
warren's but certainly as we get to the
point about discussing
uh taxes and tax reform uh or reforms of
the tax system that
uh they share an objective just to be
clear the
treasury secretary said it was something
you haven't decided on yet is that
accurate
well i think it's how to pursue what i'm
conveying is that
uh there is a shared view that those at
the top are not doing their part
obviously that corporations
could be paying higher taxes that
continues to be consistent with what the
president talked about
he had a different proposal he put
forward than the one senator warren has
put forward but you know as as was
always the case with democracy in action
when it's the appropriate time i'm sure
they'll discuss and he will discuss with
others what their views are of how to
address this moving forward and then
also
the eu uh is starting legal action
against the united kingdom for not
honoring brexit conditions
does the u.s support this action and is
the president particularly concerned
given his um
support for the good friday agreement
yeah let me see if i have something on
this for you and if not i'm happy to get
something for you after the briefing
um we continue to encourage both the
european union and the uk government to
prioritize
pragmatic solutions to safeguard and
advance the hard-won peace in
northern ireland uh we would of course
encourage you to speak to those
governments directly about any
legal actions uh president biden has
been unequivocal
in his support for the belfast good
friday agreement this agreement has been
the bedrock of peace stability and
prosperity
for all the people of northern ireland
and we also welcome cooperation between
our british and irish counterparts
on the northern irish border protocol go
ahead
just a quick housekeeping one when does
when does gene start
let me see what i have here for you
he's currently i do know he's currently
in california and so he'll be
working remotely for a period of time
until he
um has his vaccine uh let me see if i
have a timeline for him
i'll check on that for you hans that's a
quick follow-up and maybe but
will he be in the west wing or the eeob
where will his office be uh well he will
be
working remotely for some period of time
he his title will be
white house american rescue plan
coordinator and senior adviser to the
president try to fit that on a
card i don't know um long one but
impressive um
he'll work out of the white house and
have a team working with him in terms of
where his office will be i'm not sure
that's been formally determined quite
yet
okay and then you know zeke's question
is sort of does the president have any
opinions or thoughts on how americans
should be spending that they're getting
the stimulus checks
more broadly speaking all this money is
gonna be coursing through states and
localities and cities
does the president have any sort of
preferences does he have any red lines
what they shouldn't do if there are any
tax cuts
would that bother him how is he thinking
about the money once it goes out the
door
to states and localities well the
original purpose of the
state and local funding was to keep cops
firefighters other central employees
at work and employed and it wasn't
intended
to cut taxes so i think he certainly
hopes that
that's how the funding is used but part
of the implantation of it will be
under the purview of our soon to be
starting uh coordinator
and senior advisor to the president and
uh i'm sure he'll be focused on that
money's coming into states localities
and in some cases it hasn't been as
disastrous it was maybe earlier thought
it might be and the shortfall isn't as
great
some of the states localities could find
themselves with surpluses
and so i guess what you're saying here
is that the president and gene by
extension
would be opposed any tax cuts that any
states or localities would pass through
that they'd rather have it be more on
the building front or more on the hiring
front is that
am i hearing you correctly well i think
the intention as we've long talked about
uh was to keep people in their jobs and
their roles if there's our
like cops and firefighters and others uh
if there are surpluses i'll have to talk
to our nec team if there's
what considerations they have for that
particular issue
go ahead thank you oh appreciate it um
just circling back to governor okomo
the washington post reported on sunday
that a top formal advisor
who also happens to be new york's
vaccine bazaar
and called county officials to gauge
their loyalty to cuomo
amid his sexual harassment investigation
um i wanted to see if the president is
concerned that vaccine
distribution in new york has become
politicized
and is the administration taking any
steps to make sure that political
favoritism
is not tainted um is not taking access
to vaccine for new yorkers
well first let me say we all read those
stories one was in
your outlet there were a number of other
stories uh out there
um and certainly we found them um
concerning
uh about uh this inappropriate reported
behavior
there are a number of checks in the
system i will say um the cdc has the
ability to track and monitor
distribution and we've talked about this
a little bit before as it relates to
uh equitable distribution of vaccine
supply and so
every vaccine box is tracked and we know
where it's going
and uh the cdc can track that and
monitor and if there are
uh you know we work uh to ensure
that um it is equitably distributed and
that there are not steps that are taken
that are
uh concerning the other piece is that we
work uh
with local health officials across the
state right we work with
officials uh you know who are who are
overseeing distribution
in all of the different cities
localities uh to ensure
uh that they are getting what they need
that uh there are no breaks in the
system
and we are engaged across the board
especially in a state like new york
and we uh certainly track any concerns
uh that come up
um so you know there we were concerned
of course about the reports of this
inappropriate behavior
uh but we also have a number of staffs
that are already in the system
uh to ensure that the people of new york
the people of any state
um you know um are getting the the
vaccine
distributed distributed fairly and
equitably given those reports over the
weekend
did you take any extra steps to take
another look at especially in new york
because that allocation is quite
concerning i would think for
not only our new yorkers but all
americans of course we are constantly
monitoring i'm not
i'm i've not been made aware of any
incidents that uh that uh
that have been raised in relation to
this report
um there are regular reports out of
states that we take a look at
even before this report but uh if there
is i can see
with our team if there's anything new as
it relates to this report from this
weekend and then also
um you know on cuomo just following up
for an earlier question
it's our understanding that governor
cuomo not just he doesn't
merely participate in these calls at
least
but he is in fact a leads them as
a big um player in terms of organizing
them
and so we're curious if the president
has any concerns with that with his sort
of
level of leadership over this critical
piece in
um you know the covenant response
well it would be up to the nga to
determine if they were to make a change
on that front it's also up to the
legislature and
others in new york to determine uh if
they're
if he still has the confidence of the
people
in the state but our focus from here
from the federal government
is of course supporting that independent
investigation which we adamantly do
but also working with governors across
the country
with the nga with the dga with others to
address issues that come up uh or or
hear from them and
listen to them and work with them on
cove and addressing code getting the
pandemic under control
etc and we will continue to work with a
range of governors across the country
trump administration it was not set up
this way my understanding is
under the trump administration um vice
president pence was doing these weekly
calls and
this has been a shift to go from pence
to somebody like
governor cuomo at this point so i'm
wondering if perhaps the white house
wants to shift it back
towards the white house or away from the
nga which happens to be led by a
governor who has a lot of
things going on in the state at the
moment well one of the reasons that
it's been set up to engage directly with
governors
is that there were
operational aspects of the way the last
administration approached kovid
and approached kova the distribution of
vaccines or approached planning and
engagement with governors that
wasn't working they didn't feel they had
the information they needed they didn't
know when
they were getting vaccine supply and our
effort was to
work much more directly in a range of
means uh
in a range of ways up and down the ranks
in these states to ensure
that we were addressing the local needs
as they came up
so i'm i'm not aware of any plan to
shift that approach comfortable with
cuomo
essentially leading these weekly calls
again this is up to i think he's in that
position because he is head of the nga
uh and it's up to the nga to determine
if that's where they want to see things
moving forward
specifically on immigration um given the
fema deployment to the border
i wanted to see if the administration is
going to ask congress for any additional
emergency money to secure the border or
fund resources
to house or provide additional care for
children who are there
uh the the the problems is i've uh won
there's an immigration bill that we have
certainly proposed
um that we hope that members of both
parties will take seriously and
engage in a constructive conversation
about
uh the issues and challenges we're
facing are not fully
are not solely about funding at all um
but i'm not aware of additional requests
for immediate funding i'm happy to check
on that as well
and then one absolute last question
about
the um this is related to some
appointments of the department of
justice
um my colleague nancy cook of bloomberg
news wrote a story last week i believe
noting that liberal groups are growing
concerned that there are a number of
attorneys who are being appointed to top
positions who have a background of
defending large companies
including connections to apple and
facebook
and these groups are asking that some of
these attorneys recuse themselves in
matters of anti-antitrust matters
i was wondering if the administration or
the white house shares that concern
and is considering asking them to refuse
themselves on some of these larger
big-time anti-trust matters that will be
coming up
presumably i'd have to look at it more
closely it may be a decision for the
department of justice to make but i will
look more closely and see if we have a
view from
the white house about recusals go ahead
go ahead thank you
oh okay go ahead go ahead in the back in
the back thank you very much jane
a quick follow-up on the border does
president biden plan to visit the border
i don't have any trips to preview for
you at this point in time if we do we
will certainly preview them
something he's considering or talking
about i don't have anything to preview
for you okay going back to the
uh the scene i know you say the goal is
to vaccinate americans first but
i want to go back to the ultrasonic
supply sitting here in the u.s without
approval
uh many countries are seeking brazil is
also seeking access to the supply and
brazil is an urgent
need um scientists around the world are
saying that brazil is
a threat to the world right now the
situation there the crisis there
dr dr voucher said last week that the
most important thing to do in brazil
is to get more people vaccinated as soon
as possible uh
but brazil is struggling so uh which the
when can we expect that these countries
that are needed
in right now and can use right now
because they have the approval there
what can we expect they can have access
to maybe this supply
maybe in june or july well
we are engaged with a range of countries
and i'm certain with brazil as well
about their requests um and
we are of course focused the president
is focused on ensuring that
all americans uh all adult americans are
vaccinated that's
uh the first objective here uh but we
are
uh looking forward to being uh you know
players in the global community is
effort to address the global pandemic
there was a significant amount
announcement made on friday coming out
of the quad summit
about supply that we have agreed to uh
to work with the quad members to provide
to
a range of countries and regions and we
are so certainly open to discussing
and considering um you know when we can
provide additional supply but i don't
have anything to preview for you predict
in terms of the timeline
we're going to just go on because we're
otherwise we're not gonna get to
everybody go ahead
um so a new poll from npr and marist
said that nearly half of republican men
won't get the vaccine when it's
available to them and
and i know that last week you said that
the democratic administration
might not always be the best messenger
to communicate to everyone kind of the
importance
and the benefits of getting the vaccine
and so i just wanted to ask if the white
house is making plans to try to boost
republican
receptivity to the vaccine and can you
share what any of the ideas are
sure um first the president's goal is to
vaccinate all americans not just those
who voted
for him right now the phase we're in is
that demand for the vaccine still
outstrips supply
uh we won't be in that phase forever but
right now the big issue is
access and people wanting to have access
to the vaccine
and so we're focusing on how to make it
as convenient and accessible for
americans
as possible and i talked about this very
briefly last week
but we know we need to meet everyone
where they are and that includes
conservatives um and ensure there are
trusted messengers who
lead the way in those engagements uh 81
percent of republicans said they would
trust their own
vitamin component this weekend to
provide reliable information about a
covid
19 vaccine uh you know this is
consistent with what i was conveying
last week and some of the data that
we've seen internally about how
yes there are a number of prominent
officials out there who
if they were more vocal about getting
the vaccine we'd certainly support that
but
also doctors and local health providers
are
we see poll after poll are are the most
one of the most trusted
authorities in communities regardless of
people's political affiliation
as our religious leaders um and uh
local uh leaders as well so we are very
mindful of that and thinking of ways to
support empower uh you know help fund uh
those efforts uh we're also meeting
regularly with conservative groups faith
leaders and rural stakeholders
department partner with them
in boosting vaccine confidence but i
also have a couple of examples that i
found interesting hopefully you do as
well
uh you know we are focused on earned
media and establishing partnerships with
trusted messengers right now
we will quickly move to a public a big
public campaign which will be run out of
hhs there's even some funding
in the american rescue plan for that
that will be a part of it that hopefully
we'll have more to stay on in a couple
of weeks but
uh some a couple of examples tomorrow dr
fauci and dr collins
will be hosting an event with
evangelical leaders to discuss the
vaccine and how we can partner with them
dr collins uh has appeared on the 700
club
uh we also have done of course a range
of engagements with different
communities where there's vaccine
hesitancy doctor nunez smith on the
shade room dr fauci
did an interview with gloria stefan
which now i want to go find and watch
myself as i'm sure many of you do
uh so we are trying to be creative on
earned media to
meet people where they are but we're
also mindful of
empowering supporting um local
trusted voices because we've seen that
in poll after poll to be
an effective way of reaching a range of
communities dr fauci said uh recently
that for president trump getting
involved in this big game changer for
uh encouraging republicans to take the
vaccine do you guys agree and does
president biden want to see
trump get involved in this messaging
well if if
former president trump woke up tomorrow
and wanted to be more vocal about the
safety and efficacy of the campaign of
the of the vaccine
certainly we support that uh but uh
also i think what's important to note is
that as i noted
81 percent of republicans said they
would trust their own doctor or health
care provider
and that's an important place to invest
every other living former president
or most of them if not all of them has
participated in public campaigns
they did not need an engraved invitation
to do so so
he may decide he should do that if so
great but there are a lot of different
ways to engage
to reach out to ensure that people of a
range of political
support and backing uh know the vaccine
is safe and
and uh safe and effective go ahead and
thanks so much
first question back on the border there
were lawyers who
interviewed some children that were in
facilities the children described
sleeping on the floor
being hungry not being not seeing the
sun for days
how is that acceptable for the blind
administration to keep children in
those sorts of conditions given the fact
that she said you you were an
administration that's going to be more
humane than
the previous one well these let me first
say this is um
heartbreaking uh it's a very emotional
issue for a lot of people
um and it's very difficult and
challenging
and obviously these tbp facilities are
not made for kids
so one of the reasons uh or a driving
reason why
uh the president has pushed to take all
of the actions
that i outlined earlier when phil asked
the question is because we want to
expedite
getting these kids out of these cbp
facilities
as quickly as possible and that's our
goal and our objective and into shelters
as quickly as possible then into
sponsored homes while their cases are
being
considered and adjudicated uh we are
trying to work through what was a
dismantled and unprepared system
because of the the f the role of the
last administration
it's going to take some time but we are
very clear-eyed about what the problems
are and very focused on
uh putting forward solutions i
understand the idea of these facilities
not being designed by children
but children being hungry sleeping on
the floor not being allowed outside for
days at a time
why is that acceptable to go on even for
one more day why is that something
that's not being outlawed right now
how is the administration not stopping
that today well yamiche it's not
acceptable
but i think the challenge here is that
there are only
there are not that many options so the
options are and we have a lot of critics
but many of them are not putting forward
a lot of solutions the options here are
send the kids back
on the journey send them to unvetted
homes
or work to expedite moving them into
shelters where they can get
health treatment by medical doctors by
educational resources legal counseling
mental health counseling
that's exactly what we're focused on
doing and this is an across the
administration effort
that we are committed from the top to
making changes on as quickly as possible
you just talked about vaccine hesitancy
i know you said that there are going to
be resources for dr fauci and others in
the administration to go out and reach
out to trusted sources
based on polling and conversation with
experts the government is not the answer
for reaching
a lot of the gop men in particular that
were found to be hesitant of the vaccine
is it a waste of time to have those
officials go there
and are there other things that the
government should be doing that maybe
are
different than having the face of the
people that many of these voters don't
trust
being the ones talking to them i i don't
mean to cut you off but i think i just
answered this exact question
um earlier with some of the specific
steps we're taking and examples
of people we're putting forward in our
efforts to empower
support local medical doctors experts
who are
very powerful and impactful um
voices in a range of communities so
that's exactly what we're doing and i
could not agree with you more we agree
with you you know that
it's not we are not always the right
voice uh the biden administration or
somebody standing at this podium
to a range of conservative communities
and we have to meet people where they
are which is why we're taking
a number of approaches and using a
number of tactics of black leaders
some black experts saying that there was
too much focus
on the hesitancy in the african-american
community and that might be used as an
excuse
for not having enough access to black to
black people in this country that
this administration and others focus too
much on black people and their hesitancy
for the vaccine
i may not be understanding your question
we're not provo i would say this
law leaders say that black black
people's hesitancy to the vaccine
might be as an excuse for low
vaccination rates
as well as access to the vaccine so
there are some that are saying when you
talk too much about
african-american people and their
hesitation to the vaccine that that then
becomes an excuse that those are
the arguments that african-american
leaders and others are making right now
an excuse within the community or an
excuse for us yeah excuse for the
administration and others to say
black people aren't getting vaccinated
at higher rates because they're hesitant
i would say that we we just look at the
data our objective is to ensure that
all american adults have access to the
vaccine or vaccinated and that we are
doing everything we can
to reach communities and people where
they are so
that our approach has been based on the
data and the statistics we were looking
at
we have taken a number of steps
including
putting forward supporting more
community health centers now there are
900
mobile clinics to get into communities
mass vaccination
sites to ensure that the vaccine is
accessible
and in a range of communities where we
did through data see hesitancy so i
would just
refute that i don't think that's an
accurate uh a description of our
approach
i know we have to wrap this up here
because i think you guys have to gather
for the event
but just one year
setting up a detention center at the
convention center they can house 300
migrant children 3 000 migrant
immigrant teenagers is that consistent
with the administration's
validated values and how what
protections
are being put in place in that facility
to make sure that
these teenagers are cared for well i'd
have to
look at the specific report i would say
that we have been looking at
additional facilities to open to move
children
unaccompanied children into facilities
where they can receive
access to health care educational
resources
mental health resources legal resources
and certainly we would ensure that we
are meeting the standard that we have
set out
but i'd have to check into those
specific reports since they happen while
we were
up here thank you everyone
you